now
um somebody who i didn't include in my
top 10 list because technically his
album came out in january
or december of last year and someone who
i consider
um to have the best melodies in all of
all of hip-hop
is roddy rich and i know a lot of people
have been
you know and i i don't disagree with
anybody who thinks roddy rich should be
on that list i just kind of i think
marathi rich is
one of the best song makers right period
i agree i think righty rich is a better
right rich caret you know i'm saying i'm
not saying he can't i know for sure
but i also believe he's like a product
of 2019 more so than
2020 and um his album lived a lot this
year man
it did but it it came out last year you
know right
right that's that's just how i base it
off and also i don't think
when i think of best rappers like i
don't
for me i don't put roddy rich in that
category he's not a person that comes to
mind
he can make a great song but when i
think like the best rappers it's going
to make me go ooh
nah it's not necessarily righty rich